okay so there's like we were saying
there's a relationship between the
kidney architecture and the target
architecture they code together so you
can tell a lot of the assumptions of the
nagi a architecture by what Guk is doing
or and or not doing okay
so we're working with a demon Nadia
basic and we want to make sure of a
couple things we want to make sure that
our head does not remain on the line of
attack so if this line is here only my
hips remain on the line of attack so as
I go back my head is perpendicular to
the line do not call back this way
then we want to also make sure that my
head does not move forward into the
technique because the energy is coming
up at my head
even at the basic level the head has to
go that way so they had to go that way
my hips must continue forward my hips
cannot go backwards so I can't have my
butt go down first and then I lowered
myself so you can do it very
sequentially by Center forward come off
your heels let your body release
[Music]
look for the inside arm release if you
have a handle on that go ahead and work
with the flexion of your Center and
contract it allow yourself to be sprung
out of the position and find your back
foot as your follow so I'm here spring
this allows me to keep my hips forward
my head back all right let's try it try
to remember our basic falling geometry
this requires a lot of energy to take
the head and turn it topsy-turvy
it's not very efficient what we tend to
do is create an angle see the diagonal
and then we push and pull so here's the
head and when I push and pull then the
head just went down you see that and it
switched places with the feet and you
get a topsy-turvy effect so sometimes we
do it ahead go on for
[Music]
or oh there this and the push here and
we went to here safe concept okay
[Music]
so if you watch it is that grateful and
he's gonna move down on this side you
see his fitting aren't they see that so
if he goes you probably don't even know
how but try to go straight back you can
barely see he still had a turn straight
back so your head is on that one and now
he tries to fit that one see that can't
do it so that water doesn't fit our face
okay so he's gonna do his regular static
who can me that then I do that side but
loose on the technique then he does the
other side
[Music]
that same spinning rotation but he's
actually going forward but some
different architectural ways of being so
as you saw i've never he's not gonna
have his head he doesn't get to control
his head because i'm spinning this okay
that's what makes them fall so he can't
go back then the way i do Mike the tiny
the in space at the beginning he can't
turn into a forward roll say we can't do
the front break fault
so you gonna he's here here okay
and we'll take him now to the
contracting center break ball move this
Way's good for Nagin because what you
find is most logins don't have a base
and they fall fall right back but you're
gonna have like a two-count rhythm so
one two one two
see how he's finding his foot he's being
squeezed out of the technique by my
spinal displacement got it okay let's
try it it's just a training tool hold
down and out with my base so like I
always say see it's not my arm just note
my arms not in it because my arm is
already done the arm is done hope you
see it's already done finding my crown
[Music]
make it positive in your entry
don't throw down squeeze them out this
allows him to work on a spinal or a base
or total structured displacement mr. and
it also allows me to work on the in
aspect of that if I present myself as a
unified structure when he moves forward
with Edie me I've moved forward or
backwards as a single organization not
segmented Hey
so he goes whoo he just moves me and I'm
in that mop Center
[Music]
then I'm going to commit to the entry
long as I walk like that I'll be able to
be displaced you understand so what we
can to make themselves display scible
then you require the integrity of the
capacity of displacing okay so I don't
want to go on down you're like that's
really heavy over there well remember I
was trying to go like this so I don't
feel like this
- let the Vator people who help you get
stronger you going boom that way with
your body and the arm is going that way
so you get the stick to spin you're
going train a little bit working more
dynamically without taking it to where
he's actually going forward which is I
would say function but you might you
might end up in a spot like you're here
I'm in the back I'm in the back corner
and I want to know how to do this
dynamic and even if he's going forward
and there's a lot of energy which he
didn't do I still have the X pattern
right do you understand
it's still there but it's not tactile II
put in place that the inertia of the
momentum all that stuff is making
different fulcrums but here I'm actually
going to use this by I'm going to put my
hip right in this part where my hand is
for this push part
okay you guys are incessantly so my hip
is gonna go here boom and he has to when
I do my projection he'll do the same
with kami but I'm not making it as loose
you understand and he does the same with
kami
let's charge it close the Xbox there's a
little bump so I'm making that stick do
that
[Music]